pour
m
rando pays vous propose cette semaine
une émission spéciale pour en apprendre
un peu plus sur les milieux naturels de
la réunion en compagnie du naturaliste
joël dupont
la réunion est un paradis de la
randonnée entre les cirques le volcan
les forêts primaires les bords de plage
le choix d'itinéraires et d'ambiance et
grands pour qui aime découvrir son île
cette diversité de milieux du décor
spectaculaire la réunion la doit à son
caractère dit l'océanic volcaniques un
petit territoire perdu dans l'océan
indien qui n'a jamais été attaché un
continent et surtout dont le relief est
très prononcé dans les milieux naturels
où ils sont extrêmement diversifié sa
certainement une des caractéristiques de
la réunion puisque on est quand même le
plus haut point de l'océan indien avec
3000 70 m et donc les milieux c'est en
fonction de l'altitude et ils sont
définis essentiellement par le climat
qui est définie par l'altitude et par
l'exposition au vent
suivons qu'on est orienté au vent donc
sous l'effet des alizés qui apporte
beaucoup de pluie ou sous le vent où on
a des
des milieux qui peuvent être plus sec
surtout en basse altitude comme partout
au monde l'altitude et le climat sont
donc les principaux facteurs pour
distinguer les habitats naturels
la réunion a toutefois cette
particularité que son relief est très
chaotique le volcanisme l'érosion et
l'action de l'eau ont façonné au fil des
millénaires un paysage explosé à l'image
des cirques une formation géologique
unique au monde qui lui a valu son
inscription au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
comme la réunion un relief très
disséquer on a des centaines de ravine
de rempart de canyon tout autour de
l'île
et là effectivement on a également des
sous unités je veux dire dans les grands
habitat qui pour lui même altitude
suivant qu'on est sur un versant de
ravine exposé à l'est ou à l'ouest ou
sur une crête ou au contraire dans un
fonds drive in on a également des
habitats très très différents les
habitats et sous habitat sont donc très
nombreux sur l'île une richesse
exceptionnelle pour un territoire de
seulement 2500 12 kilomètres carrés ici
il faut être un spécialiste pour
apprendre à les différencier tous
le randonneur lui pourra aisément
distinguer reconnaître les grands
ensembles dans les eaux le milieu les
habitats qu'on va le plus rencontrer les
milieux c'est la forêt tropicale de
montagne qui pousse bébour plaine des
chicots
notre dame de la paix des choses comme
ça qui est une milieu relativement
encore bien représenté à la réunion
parce qu'il a échappé je disais aux
grands défis défrichement grande partie
ensuite il ya la tamarinaie qui est
toujours une forêt de montagne qui est
dominé par une espèce de d'acacia
endémique
on appelle le grand camarade et au plus
haut en altitude on a des jeunes qui
sont au dessus de la forêt qui sont des
zones plutôt bissau nantes avec comme
espèces dominantes des brandes ou des
plantes qui sans être des bruyères un
peu l'aspect des bruyères c'est pour ça
qu'on appelle ça des végétations
éricoïde du latin erika qui venir
bruyère dans les bas un autre grand
facteur est à prendre en compte l'homme
les activités humaines ont toujours
exercé de fortes pressions sur la nature
depuis qu'il est arrivé sur l'île
l'homme a donc considérablement
transformé le milieu naturel
en commençant par celui qui était à sa
portée immédiate
c'est pourquoi dans les bas les milieux
naturels ont presque tous disparu
la réunion c'est un peu comme une
assiette renverser la colonisation et il
y mène est donc les grands défrichements
pour l'agriculture se sont effectuées
surtout sur les bas jusqu à moyenne
altitude
donc il ya la forêt tropicale humide de
basse altitude et en reste des beaux
vestiges sûr dans le sud est de saint
philippe sainte-rose et dans quelques
grandes rave innovants comme la rivière
des marsouins la rivière du mât et puis
vous avez la forêt semi sèche qui elle
est sous le vent qui dans le s'étendait
en gros de saint denis en passant par
l'ouest jusqu'à saint joseph qui monte
jusqu'à 6 700 mètres et ça par contre
sur les planètes il y en a plus du tout
elle a été totalement détruite et ceci
depuis le début de la colonisation
humaine quand il ya eu la première
grande culture d'exportation qui était
le café en plus une forêt plus sèche
donc plus sensible aux incendies dont
elle a eu lui également aime beaucoup
ravagés par les feux et elle ne reste
plus que des lambeaux souvent très
dégradée dans les ravines
de la région au vent aujourd'hui la
réunion peut se vanter d'abord été
encore sur près d'un tiers de son
territoire une forêt primaire un taux
exceptionnel comparé à d'autres îles
océaniques comme maurice où seulement 2
% du territoire et préserver mais il ne
faut pas se réjouir trop vite
si la réunion bénéficie d'un relief
exceptionnelle qui la protège en partie
de l'urbanisation
d'autres menaces fait sur ces milieux
naturels comme les espèces exotiques
envahissantes